welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and even more details about
Marvel's upcoming series Agatha darkhole
Diaries have emerged including a new
image of Agatha's coven holding a seance
are they resurrecting Wanda because this
new image paired with what we already
know about the series has led to fans to
speculate that the series could bring
back the Scarlet Witch from Earth 616
wand Max mop after she brought the
rubble of wagor mountain down upon
herself at the end of Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse manness in fact One
Division and Agatha actor a F confirmed
in a now deleted Instagram comment that
Wanda will in fact appear in the series
all of this new info raises the question
how much inspiration will show runer
Jack Schaefer take from The Witches Road
comic storyline and will wander herself
play any significant role in this series
is Elizabeth ol and the big Cameo that
she and um and vision white C PA bety
said would be coming is she our Messiah
will she save us this is the sneak peek
where we take the tempature of the
future of nerd and joining me this
this glorious week it was her all along
it's Jessica Clemens hi I'm the nosy
neighbor it's me the nosy neighbor very
excited to talk about this I'm so
excited for Agatha so excited for any
Cameo honestly and we're so pumped to
have you here I I've mentioned this a
few times on the channel but you know um
I'm going to be on paternity leave I
think as of today the baby may be on the
way when this airs so you know you're
going to see Jess on the channel this
month covering for me along with a
couple other familiar faces and I'm just
so grateful to Jess for doing that
thanks thank you yes just give me the
baby give how about this you hold on to
the baby I'll I'll do some new Rockstar
videos good good all right let's talk
about Agatha we're we're back to our
Wanda Vision uh Recaps this is exciting
um so all right let's let's takeone back
to that time January 2021 before I was a
walking Mesto mean a little explanation
the reason we thought misto could appear
in it it's because Jack Schaefer W
division head writer looked to be
adapting elements from John Burns West
Coast Avengers run in the late 80s and
that run included a storyline where
Mesto sends someone to kidnap W two kids
among other elements that made it into
the show like agan being Wanda's nosy
neighbor seeing a disassembled Vision
corpse on a table white Vision being in
there so I say all this to just get into
a conversation about Jack schaer's new
show Agatha and what that appears to be
adapting James Robinson's 2016 witch's
Road storyline and in this run
witchcraft is broken and Wanda has to
kind of glob Trot to fix it and find out
who broke it in the first place and it
includes a visit to the witches road
which is kind of a a dimension a plane
of existence where only Sorcerers can
visit in this story when Wanda reaches
the witch's Road she's confront she's
confronted by Agatha and has to figure
out if Agatha is acting as a friend or
as a foe I wind up having a lot of
downtime while these videos are
exporting or uploading so instead of
just twiddling my thumbs I go on ipsos
iay to answer quick survey questions and
earn points and redeem them for Amazon
gift cards ipsos isay lets you earn
extra cash through gift cards and
rewards just by taking part in research
and answering a few simple questions
there's a ton of different gift cards to
choose from but lately my go-to has been
an Amazon card especially with the
holidays coming up baby stuff I got to
buy it's just an easy way to have a
little more money for gifts for friends
and stuff for my family the surveys on
IPOs I say are quick and easy and
tailored to my interest so it never gets
boring I do them whenever I have a few
minutes to kill if you use public
transit it's a total GameChanger I
upgraded my downtime and you can too
just click the link in the description
to start earning rewards with IPOs I say
today so here's my question Jess what
from James Robinson's story will Jack
Schaefer choose to adapt and what new
stories might she tell like well Wanda's
death be what is causing witchcraft to
be broken in the MCU right now and is
Agatha's intention to bring her back so
that she can take back some of her power
maybe uh trading Billy's life for the
darkh hold or Wanda's power what do you
think well okay so I'm going to throw it
back to you for another question do we
think it's what it makes sense that it
would be Wanda's death that like Echoes
out to all the other witches and they
all lose their powers but at the end of
Wanda Vision Agatha said like there's
gonna you're not ready for what's going
to happen you need me and she was like
whatever happens I'm not gonna need you
so do we think it's because of that that
happened or do we think it's because of
Wanda
dying that's I you're asking the right
question yeah I think that's why they
showed at the beginning the teaser that
seen in the teaser is too it's too em
like I'm like you put this in there for
a reason yeah for a reason you're not
ready for what's coming would you know
on the surface refer to the events of
Multiverse of Madness right like you you
don't know what's coming where you read
the dark hold it's G to corrupt you you
need someone who can guide you through
the dark hold right that's there's that
but I think she's like I mean there's
that whole page of the dark hole that
prophecy or prophesies the Scarlet Witch
uh and I think what Agatha is referring
to isn't just like the drama that she's
going to go to but like her inability to
handle it and to break the the
undercurrent of Witchcraft because she
just hasn't had as much time with it as
Agatha did okay then from what I like
about wit's run is that Agatha is just a
ghost the entire time do you think they
were expecting it's interesting because
you're I'm kind of like oh Loki has
messed everything up for me uh when it
comes to time and what could done so a p
me wants to see Agatha be I don't think
Scarlet Witch is going to show up as a
ghost for Agatha I don't think they're
going to flip the pages I think Agatha's
Gonna Be a Ghost to herself because you
even talked about in your breakdown of
all the behind the scenes stuff the
little sneak peek that we're seeing
Agatha in different versions of herself
from W Division and I'm like what if
there is a version that is like the the
Bad Evil one that is technically dead
and that's the ghost that she's talking
to the entire time that's a stretch and
a half but I do like that that's like a
good storyline to take from that comic
book that you can plop into the TV
series maybe they could reverse the
roles right you have Agatha as a
protagonist figure you have Wanda who's
the ghost yeah that's you know Wanda
who's the ghost I just don't think do
you think Wanda's coming back I think so
I think she's too valuable of a
character to Marvel Studios just from a
business standpoint to just let her be
dead but you think it's gonna be the
entire time you don't think it's just
going to be like a episode
flashback oh oh no yeah yeah yeah they
they might flash back I think the more
value to her especially in a
supernatural show is to have like
Wanda's Spirit In The Witch's Road
plane and like she's just kind of this
ghostly Voice or this uh you know we
know that she can um what's it called
project herself into the astral plane um
that's what we saw her do in the finale
so if you look at Agatha as a spin-off
of w Vision that moment I think just
kind of shows that like uh Wanda's body
can separate from her physical body and
Kevin feige has like hinted I in the
most Koy possible terms that you know ju
we just saw Rubble collapse and then a
blast of red energy which could mean
anything you know yeah that's true and
he they love bringing that up I could
see Wanda then being the and being the
guide for The Witches run like in that
in that Forest that weird Forest I could
see her being there waiting there and
they're all that's why we see all the
witches are looking for her so they can
guide so she can guide them through the
forest because you'll get lost in there
regardless so and if we have Agatha
still being weird nosy neighbor Agatha
she doesn't know where the hell she's
going so they're going to need to use
Wanda so maybe they'll take that piece
from the storyline too of like Wanda
needs to be there to guide them to the
end we have such a nice diverse group of
witches in this coven you got sasher
zida in there you got uh alian in there
you got Patty Leone in there you got
Aubrey Plaza in there and what I want is
for each of these witches to just be
super old like Lilia caldero is like a
450y old witch from ancient not ancient
Italy but like Renaissance Italy um and
I just want these witches to just be
from like different regions and part of
like kind of the eternals of the witches
yeah right uh and that they all kind of
represent a different faction of the the
witch Empire or whatever the witch un
this the witch Illuminati you could
say and they each over see a different
Chie and the fact that like the Scarlet
Witch who is kind of the apex witch had
has vanished from this reality or died
whatever you want to say passed into
another plane has kind of screwed things
over for each of them in different ways
could it be like now that Wanda is like
dead or just gone could it be like uh
American Horror Story coven where it's
like who's the next Supreme who's going
to take the mantle next and so they're
just angry at each other the entire time
oh I hope so I do that I like different
factions of witches it reminds me of
Twilight uh where they have different
factions of vampires but this one will
be less corny and way more we're cooler
and everyone will be be wearing t-shirts
no one will be
shirtless oh my God all right side
tangent so my wife Kelly has been like
pushing me to watch Twilight the
Twilight series I have only seen the
first one and I'm like no I'm not don't
want to watch those movies and I'm like
there's so many other like movies that
we need to watch that you would have
watched and she goes I want to watch
Twilight and I'm like okay I'll watch
Twilight and she goes I'll watch movies
you like bad movies that you want to
watch so now I'm like I have to come up
with like five like bad movies not like
movies that have like good audience
scores and good letter box scores but
like bad movies that I love bad so that
we can alternate and I'll watch I'll
watch all the Twilights jees have fun
I'm not I don't think I can go back down
that road again I can't do it I can't do
it and I loved it I think I need to hold
a survey for everyone because I'm
thinking like Batman Forever would be a
good pick not a good movie movie that I
love I love Twilight okay sorry about
this CH I love Twilight but I tried to
rewatch as an adult and it is a very
cringy B it looks horrible like the
light whatever they were like was the
aesthetic of 2005 they were like yeah
woo and I was like this is bad for my TV
it is it made me gave me a headache it
was cringey it was weird and I was like
understandable through puberty I was
like this is the best thing in the world
as a grown woman I'm like this is not
and I think Batman Forever is still a
little bit better than that yeah
probably
um but you do have uh Jacob you have
Bella imprinting on that baby uhhuh have
fun can't wait can't wait for you to see
that scene and then message me and say
Jessica why do you still love him why do
you still love it what's wrong with you
um yeah I guess okay so it's not like
this show is a huge swing a lot of
people are like why does Agatha deserve
a spin-off and it's because like there's
been a long history of witch TV shows
you have Bewitched you have Charmed you
have Buffy I guess not necessarily witch
show but you know there's witch is in it
um and we have things like Wicked which
is one of the most like popular Broadway
shows of all time and a show that's
going to be coming out in theaters when
Agatha darkhole Diaries is on Disney
plus that's coming I believe
Thanksgiving 2024 oh my John Chu uh you
got Cynthia rivo Ariana Grande the guy
who played SpongeBob on Broadway is
playing her boyfriend aach yeah it's
guys it's gonna be so good so what kind
of flavor of witch are we going to get
in are we getting Charmed are we getting
Bewitched are we getting Wicked are we
getting a buffy or something darker the
witch with between all I hope we get the
witch a24 is the witch I'm praying for
that we're not getting that but I think
you're right when you're when you found
like oh she's wearing the same outfits
that she wore in the first season of w
division or in W division uh I think
we're GNA get those I think it's going
to be campy but I think when the other
witches come up that's what like knocks
it off its like ACC it's going to be
like a shock to them uh I am obsessed
with uh and I I know I'm going to say it
wrong everybody says it different uh
hekate he he yeah no matter how you say
it it's correct okay perect see see I
think he uh in even in the comics when
she kind of like started to dissolve and
die I was like oh I think this is the
character that's gonna come and really
everything up that's gonna be like
get me my powers back or I'm gonna blast
everybody to pieces and once that
happens that's when Agatha's gonna start
actually trembling do you think we will
get hekate because for a while I was
saying Hecate because I'm telling you I
had one college professor Who Loved
mythology who just had a weird way of
saying everything and would say Hecate
and among other wrong things I'm sure um
because she's like I had a Greek
Professor told me it's this and I'm like
maybe it's just messing with you um
maybe you're wrong but or she's just
wrong no I think it's hekate or HEC no
it's t it's heati
God we need to do a whole segment on
like how to say everything and don't put
me in
it are we getting are we getting her in
this show I assume one of yeah she was a
major part and she's also the I think
once and I will say that with Thor love
and thunder that was one of people's
every everyone's favorite part was
trying to uh figure out which gods were
there in the in Olympus or whatever and
I think grabbing that Greek mythology
which over is really great and important
and also she is in the comics is a very
important figure so I'm like yeah go
ahead bring her in also this is me being
an annoying person that likes Greek
mythology I love that her Greek
mythology hekate whatever you want to
call it uh her s she comes with like a
bunch of dogs you hear dogs barking and
we forget that Agatha killed a dog in W
division so like that moment will that
joke will come up in the show it has to
in my it has to come up um since we did
our Agatha video earlier this week um uh
I've been in touch with uh Scarlet Witch
updates on Twitter yeah it's such an
amazing account please follow them
they're so good and one of the things
they pointed out because when I did the
video I noticed that Jack Schaefer is
wearing the shirt that looks like a
tarot card it's like a sweatshirt that
she's wearing behind the scenes and then
uh Scarlet Witch updates on Twitter
figured out exactly what it is and it is
like the most glorious image it's like
uh it is specifically I believe the road
yeah it is the road which at first I was
like the road no it's like the road so
you got witches Road you got yellow
brick road you got like the serpent
crown that looks like the one Lilia
caldero wears you got the triple
goddesses and the triple goddesses are
the embodiment of heati so hell yeah oh
it is yeah it is it is so uh hiati or
Wanda are just gonna be our Mesto and
Quicksilver of this season of Agatha
calling it now um but uh so we have
sasher we have Ali we have have um uh um
auy Plaza if hiati needs to be Greek
could we have gal G do as
hiati bye Jessica thanks for com back to
hang out with us I'm sorry that I scared
you away
immediately look she's got to be tired
of being dragged out in these bad DC
movies which just it's stupid music and
she's like I'm gonna have a quick line
and like you know what just it's they're
misusing her I'm not trying to be this
I'm not trying to do this person that's
what she gets for choosing DC over
Marvel I'm sure Mar she auditioned for
Marvel and she had a good a good standin
for something and she said n I'm gonna
go play Wonder Woman and Wonder Woman's
great I love her as Wonder Woman but I'm
also like it sucks that what happened to
the DC for you like I'm sorry you got
like that sucks imagine I'm
heati I forget that she did
that that she did that I forgot never
forget that she did that and she's the
like first one too she's like the first
person she gets all the ha A lot of
people did that no everyone turned it
off immediately so you only see her and
then the guy from Breaking Bad that's
like the two people that you see and I'm
like damn that
[Laughter]
sucks all right um we're gonna talk more
about like Wanda and vision's future but
real quick be sure to check out nerd
ride. shop where you can always grab the
latest and greatest and Rockstar gear we
just got some great new holiday designs
including our play on a Christmas
stories iconic fragile lamp with Iron
Man's leg order now to get yours Before
Christmas support the channel and check
out our great merch options over at nerd
ride. shop don't forget to subscribe to
all three channels of the new Rockstar
Network new rockstars the break room and
the Deep dive okay so Eric you had
mentioned you thought some of the story
could also come into play in Jack's
other show Vision Quest and I liked your
pitch for that show if you want to chat
more about that tell me more yeah yeah
so I mean I think vision is so
interesting without Wanda at the core of
Agatha vision would not fit in the show
I don't know if Vision fits in anywhere
because he's a weird soulless husk now
who just regained his memories and he's
nothing and he's nothing yeah but um but
he did regain all of his memories uh
with the ship a thesias argument and uh
I just like this idea that Vision
Breaking Free of the West ofie hex and
disappearing to wherever he is I want to
see Vision Quest as like the story of
The Truman Show after Truman leaves the
Dome of the set and just we don't know
what happens to him he bows good
afternoon good evening good night and
leaves and I and we don't know where he
he's trying to find that woman and I
think that's what vision is trying to do
now he is trying to ship aesus several
different magazine photos that look like
Wanda ripping out the eyes ripping out
the nose ripping out the mouth the hair
and just trying to piece it back
together and and he's gonna try to
reassemble ship of thesia style Wanda
and I don't mean this physically like he
to find a woman with Elizabeth ol's eyes
and just rip out Mary Kate Olson's eyes
and then uh rip off Amy Adams's scalp
and then just like plug it into um Bryce
stallas Howard's face and be like you're
my life you just chose you just chose
like four redhead
celebrities and you were like this
Elizabeth Olsen they're all variants of
each other I think they are um but but
not Mary Kate she's just a variant of
Ashley yes of course of course a variant
of the no I'm not going to make that
joke because it was never confirmed but
just research Heath Ledger OLS and twins
okay got it uh I have a question don't
research Gala do right now because I
just realized world evance was not a
good time to talk about that that was on
me that was on me my mistake my fault I
I have a question about what you but
what you said about Vision I also agree
that I don't think Vision will ever will
not show up in this it isn't it's not
necessary uh but it it's is there
something there with Wanda making this
fake version of vision right in the the
hex View and then that Vision giving the
memories and it's whatever to White
Vision that and then white Vision
escaping does that have any tangential
like connection or effect to what's
happening in Agatha's show does that
make sense cuz it feels like a piece of
Wanda's magic is just out there now into
the world as a a a husk of a vision and
I feel like it needs a return or
something but I mean that body was like
vision's corpse from wakanda in Infinity
War and the only magic that's in there
is just whatever spark that uh the spark
that our vision from inside the hex gave
him you're right that a piece of her
magic is out there but I think if white
vision is still alive then that is proof
that's like sauron's ring it's like
Wanda still
alive that yes oh that's a good idea
that's oh that's a great idea okay I
mean that's a ship aesus is a witch ever
destroyed if you know a piece of her
magic lives on in like horcrux form it's
still floating around out there in space
floating around just ripping off faces
if okay so if stop it stop it what is
wrong with you today I don't know God
you're becoming a crazy person um Ben
Ben what do you think well Ely be the
fate of 616 Wanda before we head into
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars speaking of
the alive
Rich yeah well we we know that there is
like 838 Wanda Left Behind from
Multiverse of Madness I think the main
Scarlet Witch Wanda is still GNA be
alive in some form um and she's coming
back for Secret Wars or Kang Dynasty
because I think the best way to do Kang
Dynasty is to just like compile every
Marvel hero who has some blood on their
hands for damaging the Multiverse in
some way you know Peter Parker Kamala
Khan do strange shuni by using the Rings
to like you know the Rings were used to
open up the barrier where the dweller of
the darkness could come and that was
from some other realm that could have
been good for the Multiverse um Monica
Rambo like everybody who did something
and I think Sylvie and I think Wanda are
part of that you know my God so and I'm
trying to think like how does Marvel get
a billion dollar movie out of that I
think the names I just listed there I
think get a billion dollars out of that
movie Easy I mean if Peter if
Spider-Man's in it you get Spider-Man's
in it you're grabbing Sylvie from Loki
you're grabbing like ma one major person
from one Major's successful show because
you're getting Wanda you're getting
Spider-Man and you're getting Loki's uh
variant yeah that's like enough uh I
mean I'll watch it I'll watch it 10
times for Secret Wars but for Kang
Dynasty that's what I'm thinking for
Kang Dynasty that's the lineup for
Secret Wars that's where you bring out
the you know the guys in their 60s
that's when you get hug Jack Robert
Jenny Jun your Toby McGuire you can get
the oldtimers for that cuz I think
that's what secret War needs to be it
needs to be every reality but you need
like a really exciting Avengers lineup
that's just been in the continuity we've
been watching the past few years and I
think those are the all star of the past
few years I agree I agree with that
completely whole heart sorry moonnight I
guess moonnight can be there too because
he's oscared he'll be flapping around
somewhere my sweet baby angel I love
him uh he'll he won't be able to figure
out the chain that's connected do his
mattress or get past the sand around his
yeah everyone's like get your
together he's
like Aus
Le all right let's do a quick heat check
we know marvel is gonna have kind of a
lesser presence in 2024 in our lives and
I think that's a good thing I think we
need a time to breathe and we need to
spend more time on like you know uh
Dune and dune Godzilla fos
Dune you didn't bring up Wonka once
Wonka well Wonka is now won is in our
lives now
Paddington uh inside out so yeah there's
other great franchises out there we'll
enjoy those but then we'll get Deadpool
3 but I want to ask you is this a good
course correct would you rather just
give us like things like iron heart in a
Spider-Man freshman year in the next six
months absolutely uh but I'm also a
hungry person and I will eat up any show
that Marvel gives me I will keep eating
those shows up but I do like their
restructure of like let's step back for
a second let's let's give ourselves some
time to breathe figure out how we're
going to do this because we we just need
to now put it on the right course um so
I agree with that I understand it but I
will gladly easily eat up anything they
throw my way and I would love it yeah I
think one drawback of these uh of the
deals that the union signed with these
Studios and streamers is that like I
think what's kind of scary about it is a
reason why they were willing to sign
these deals is they're like all right
we'll just make less of all this stuff
and we won't have to hire as many actors
and writers for things like capitalism
isn't dead people it's it's gonna be
hard to kill it it is very hard I don't
know I read Bob iger's quote and he
sounded like a madman being like no no
our sequels we ain't doing that
ever again also make our families
white
out he did I read between the lines I
read what he said I know what he's
talking about also when you're gone I
want you to know it's it's going to be
this unhinged of content from me please
please yes yes yes yes yes yes I'm going
to be watching everything with my baby
and I'm just going to be like absorb
everything see they're going to they're
going to stop inviting me to press
events they're going to be like Jessica
said this crazy thing about Bob Iger I'm
like it's not crazy if he said
it sorry
sorry so continue I love it oh my
God ah yep yep yep and then um so yeah
hi Bob hi Bob if you're in the audience
just to to quote our um the villain of
our times is that crazy he said hi Bob
oh God all right we got to leave it
there so I'm
disappear uh other than some pre-shot
videos that you'll see on the channel
and then I think the next time you'll
see me uh with Jessica is going to be in
our uh we have like a special final day
of the year episode of sneak peek coming
up on New Year's Eve so stick around for
that but it's going to be a fun couple
weeks and everyone have a wonderful
holiday and thank you Jess it's so good
to see you again be back I'm so excited
I'm so excited my content won't be as
unhinged I promise it will be normal
It'll be such normal content you guys
will be like wow Jessica's never been
this normal in her life it's going to be
a great time and I'm very excited it's
going to be fun uh so follow J at Lulu
Clemens follow me at eavas and uh we'll
see you all soon thanks for watching bye
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
a